-Thank you so much for being on
the show. I appreciate it.
-Dude, I've wanted to be here
forever, man.
Thanks for finally having me.
-Oh, my God. Come on.
I want to talk about
your film "Devotion."
But first I got to say, congrats
on "Top Gun: Maverick."
What a great job you did
in that film.
-Thank you, thank you.
-You were amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was like, you're crushing it.
I watched it on the IMAX.
It was so fun.
You just popped off the screen.
But then the movie went on
to make over a billion dollars,
by the way.
-A billion. It's not bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How does it feel to be
in such a giant movie?
-I mean, it's incredible.
It's definitely changed my life.
I'm feeling grateful
for every moment.
I still feel like people don't
know my name.
Everybody calls me Hangman,
still, which is great.
I did get to do a really cool
thing with Jerry Bruckheimer.
Jerry Bruckheimer, who is
the producer of "Top Gun."
-Legendary.
-He threw a billion-dollar party
at his house --
didn't cost a billion dollars.
It's because we crossed
a billion dollars.
But he threw a billion-dollar
party at his house.
-You got to feel like --
You go, "That's it. I'm on top
of the world."
-Yeah, I mean, it was like --
He had the Porsche
from the movie.
He had the motorcycle
All the cast was there.
We're just all hanging out.
We're playing trivia games,
having the best time.
And I feel like because I seem
like a guy who loves karaoke --
[ Laughter ]
-You seem like a guy?
-I feel like I'm a guy
that you're like,
"Oh, he has one drink
and wants to do karaoke."
I'm not that guy.
-Wow!
-Yeah, I just feel like I give
off that vibe.
-Yeah, you got a karaoke vibe.
-Yeah, I'm like the guy
who's like, "Okay, he'll grab
a drink with me."
-"We'll do a song, yeah."
-"He's not going to be good, but
he's going to have a good time."
I actually hate karaoke.
But Jerry, at this party,
he teamed everybody up
to do karaoke.
And my song was
"Take My Breath Away"...
[ Laughter ]
...which is, like, just not
in my octave range at all.
-No, it's hard to be
in anyone's -- Yeah.
That's a really tricky song.
-And so Danny Ramirez,
who plays Fanboy in the movie,
we were paired up to sing
that song.
And I sang it. And I go,
"Hey, dude, we just got to
fully commit to this thing.
If we're going to do this,
we got to fully commit."
But I think we kind of,
like, overcommitted.
And we went, like --
We basically were, like, rolling
around on couches and, like --
-Trying to sell it.
-Rubbing centerpieces
on each other and we were like
behind curtains.
-Whatever you can do
to get some type of reaction.
-Yeah. And it was just like,
everybody was just stone-faced.
And it was like the most
powerful people in Hollywood,
everybody that I love
and respect.
-"Why am I doing this?"
-I just lost all respect
from them in a matter of
3 1/2 minutes of this song.
-You did do some -- You do some
cool things, by the way.
Because I did hear about this.
Is this true?
Tom Cruise gifted you
pilot lessons?
-Yeah. I'm a fully licensed
pilot now. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Tom has been on the show
a zillion times.
He's never gifted me
pilot lessons ever.
-You probably did something
wrong.
I don't know.
-I did, yeah.
Did he know were you
into flying?
-Yeah. I mean, while we were
shooting "Top Gun,"
we flew in all
these different airplanes.
And I just, you know, had
a real love for aviation.
So for Christmas, he gave me my
pilot's lessons, flying lessons.
So, as I was flying and getting
that license, I'd send him
pictures of all the different
stuff I was flying in.
So I was finally in
my last check ride.
I get on the ground and get back
to the hangar, and on the table
is a note from Tom that said,
"Welcome to the skies."
And it was a certificate
for stunt driving lessons.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't stop.
Tom Cruise doesn't stop.
He goes to the next level.
-He's gotten me into skydiving.
He's gotten me into
motorcycle riding.
The guy is just, you know,
he convinces you to do
all the most dangerous things
on this planet.
-He made you --
He didn't make you,
but he also gave you
a gift of skydiving?
-Yeah, that was actually --
It was actually my second date
with my girlfriend,
which it's actually our
anniversary tomorrow,
so happy anniversary.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations.
-Yeah.
-No, but tell everyone
what happens.
Because when Tom Cruise
just goes,
"Oh, let's go skydiving"
or whatever,
here's what he does.
Tell everyone.
-So, basically, I go,
"Hey, Tom" -- We were going to
go do some reshoots in London.
And I said, "Hey, man, I want to
go skydiving while I'm out here.
I hear the skydiving is great."
He goes, "Yeah."
And he sends a helicopter
for me.
But it got so windy that
the skydiving team --
I was with the U.K. skydiving
team -- they said
it's so dangerous, we should not
go skydiving.
I was like, "Alright.
I'm no hero. I'm good."
-I don't have to hear that
twice. We're good.
-So, we scrapped it, went back.
And then Tom hit me up like a
couple weeks later and was like,
"Hey, man, what are you,
scared?"
And I'm like, "What are you
talking about?"
And he's like, "You never took
me up on the skydiving."
I'm like, "Oh, I'll do it
whenever, man."
So, with the girl that I was
seeing at the time,
this is our second date,
we went skydiving.
And when I got there, Tom --
I found out that Tom's
only request is that Glen
cannot go skydiving
with another person.
He has to go solo
the first time.
So I literally have to jump out
of this plane by myself.
But the worst part is that
I couldn't find my tab
when I was falling.
-This is the nightmare that --
-It's the nightmare that
everybody talks about.
But my first thought, which is
not like a selfless thought,
but my first thought was,
"Oh, Tom just killed me.
He's going to feel so bad."
[ Laughter ]
-You're thinking about
Tom's feelings?
-I was like, "God, he pushed me
to do this thing."
-Yeah, it's really gonna hurt
his feelings.
-I'm looking for the tab and I'm
like, "You're not Tom Cruise.
You'll never be Tom Cruise.
Why did you do this?"
-And then you pulled the thing.
-And then I finally pulled it.
I was way below altitude.
-You were Tom Cruise.
-Came in hot.
-Yeah.
-Made it, went back up,
did it again.
-You did it twice?
-Yeah, twice.
-That's Glen Powell. That's what
I'm talking about there.
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it, bud.
Let's talk about your new film,
"Devotion."
You're getting great reviews
on this.
It's based on a true story.
How did you get involved
with this?
-This is a project I've been
developing for five years.
It's a project that's so close
to my heart.
I love this movie so much.
It's about the most famous
aviator duo in naval history,
first African-American naval
aviator and his wingman.
They pulled all sorts of daring
missions behind enemy lines.
Not to spoil anything,
but one of them gets shot down
behind enemy lines and the other
one crash-lands his plane
on purpose to save him.
Just this beautiful story
of how far
you're willing to go
for a wingman.
Please see it.
It's coming out on Thanksgiving.
And I just --
Take the whole family.
It's just awesome.
But yeah, it's just this project
that's just been my baby,
and I had to go meet
the families to get the rights
and put this thing together.
-They gave you the thumbs-up?
-Yeah. It was sort of like
I guess like asking for
a girl's permission to marry.
You know, it kind of felt like
you're asking, you know,
you're asking the family
to tell their story.
And I sat down with Tom Hudner,
the guy I'm playing in the movie
and I remember saying, you know,
it was after
a three-day weekend.
I thought it was
just going great.
We were having,
like, a great time,
and I was asking him about his
experience in the Korean War.
-Then he's like, "Do you want to
do karaoke?"
-He's like, "You want to do
karaoke?"
and I was like, "Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, you know, "I'd
love to play you in the movie."
And it was just
like dead silent.
And I was like, "Okay, I thought
this was going a little better."
I guess it's better for me
than it was for you.
And then he left, came back with
a signed photo of him
getting the Medal of Honor, and
he said, "Just get it right."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just get it right, buddy.
You got it right.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Glen Powell
in "Devotion."
Take a look at this.
-I'm sticking my neck out
for you.
-Sticking your neck out
with a piece of paper?
Tom.
That paper cost you nothing.
Nothing!
You know how tired I am of
people trying to help me
while looking down on me?
-I am not looking down on you.
What do you want me to do?
-Just be my wingman.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Glen Powell, everybody.
"Devotion" opens in theaters
November 23rd.